paris toi jours à la huer
les prix je volais pacs avec areski zh
dans la vie copper rand et crac crac aux
terroristes que c'était des bouteilles
d'eau et avec la différence de pression
se gonflait toi pierre évincement bruit
dépasse moins inquiet enfin
c'est une faille a pas de neige mais le
côté vert là dehors dans la neige près
bon les pompes gagne pas mal de potes
qui pourrait bien aller mais j'aimerais
bien voir de la neige en haut des airs
de temps en temps je pourrai connaître
un quoi c'est aussi très bon pour la
ville
ça
connaît tous le soutenir serait très
haut et enroule les stations de regarder
les étoiles
donc c'est un truc très connu à l'orgue
je coupe
après que j'eus tellement en leur
donnant is a good day today et au match
de balle à ce bon avec la montagne et
leurs programmes
dans les faits son endroit
refusant cependant de ces pratiques et
pensées anti rigole pas gauche c'est
quoi la pala pickering un gone sont
passés par ses parents vers la gauche
battus au
alors va tourner
montage
quelle est la route
faire
aussi madame leblanc qui arrive de la
mer remonte sur le sur le vague
weatherill heureusement
en tout cas le mec avec le truck et là
il a su parler sans ce prêt est génial
et j'ai hâte et a perdu la visibilité
qu'on a
hoard est bel et bien payé mais
aujourd'hui ça incroyable
on n'a pas gelé vue à
là
abbado dans cette
on va regarder ça donne c'est pour 7
décembre
truc toi c'est en papy main way est clos
on est depuis trop gâté maintenant on
sait la rivière noire
c'est plus sympa droite voire droite
quand tu vas bien voilà la doua très
bien le lot qui se voit là moi qui sait
vraiment à lalobbe le talent aux
ateliers rando qui arrive c'est que ces
jeux lyon voilà jeu
le board est un peu la cote avait un
petit air est non d'autres instituts se
repose
serait dans le viseur c'est pas
intéressant ces boutons bravant faire un
tour un peu plus là
attendez les gars a tourné un peu et
ouais peut-on à la bien belle rose bayal
et je pense à vous rend pas le coût de
ce c'est pas mal tiens c'est beaucoup
c'est ça allez on y va à la coop va se
tenir
devant
le secteur enregistre
pas vers la mer un peu qu'on voit le
buzz de bras noirs tu vois ma go sur la
gauche votre oeil pas je n'étais pas du
tout à fait ok bon esprit ok les
molécules bien bossé pour ça c'est pas
mr blanc proposé par enfin maintenant
passer leurs trains
je contourne c'est pour ça c'est assez
moche
pas tout ça m'a fait on
et dont elles vont serrer les coudes et
joy cool
maintenant c'est au west et rouge ps de
roubaix du volcan c'est là c'est le
rouge et blanc couleur abricot son nom
le bleu toit de l'autre la relance est
alors dans l'enseigné foulée avec
valence a pas plus plus haut à méfie toi
pour que tu restes par la houle trop tu
vas tu auras plus de vendre passe bien
avoir rappelé lundi glauque et au gabon
et quand tu montes veulent venir ou
juifs là donc on est un peu plus
c'est fini on vient par l'arrière ou
c'est bon bon ça va ça va probablement
plus au hockey la lumière